I'd like to talk to Matt about like
something has to be done well tonight
can I say this before you come on I
posted because I went on Rogan and we're
talking about the mass shootings because
he had Bernie Sanders in and when he had
Bernie smart guy like that I like that I
like that beauty right we were talking a
little bit up here and I said if Bernie
if you if Rome does mass shootings we've
got to have a problem and if Bernie's
what he came up with his hypothesis I
was like yeah I've thought of that
that's not gonna work you got nothing
like no one has a good answer everybody
I was like oh we're [ __ ]
yeah and then I said why is it always
white dudes meaning why is always white
dudes who doing the majority of the big
mass shootings not just three or four
and so I was getting [ __ ] for it online
I'm like that's weird
and then when a job X actually not white
dudes here's the list they sent me this
list has like all these different
colored guys on it black white Mexican
just a ton of list not a ton of white
guys like I don't know 12 I'm like how
that's [ __ ] crazy and they're like
you have the narrative that's the news
it's white dudes blah blah blah and it's
[ __ ] up and this from a black guy and
so I thought it's from white guy so I
was like that is [ __ ] though I was I
was wrong man I thought was just white
dudes doing this mass shooting so I
posted I don't get involved with this
stuff it's not what I'm about
I like to live on my dumb ass I'm silly
I break down fight so I tell jokes
that's what you cannot a journalist you
definitely could post some like this
have you been in the but my point is is
I didn't do any research I just post
that whatever it's just a polarizing
topic especially with your audience you
got it doesn't mean the political see
you bright Walker like [ __ ] yeah noise
until my dick joke or something when
he's bringing down a fight okay
slashers Rusin Callen well but then then
people DME friends of my clothes like
hey brother I I know what you're saying
I'm with you here's the thing that came
from a guy who's mainly involved with
white supremacy
you might know him mr. Duke blah blah
blah it was a propaganda thing that they
posted that's this isn't actually true
like the FBI came out said and that's
actually not how it is
I went you had one bite of chip he duped
you nobody but a ton of people sent me
that and I was like what am i doing in
post my brother told me not to I hear
you I was like what am i doing it so I
brought it down
but it's cool you not pull it down I
went I went good listen I'm out so he
gonna do my research but I think you're
also somebody was like this sucks in
putting it mildly we have a problem like
whatever it's going on
none of us no matter what you or where
you are on the gun control debate none
of us want to live in a society where
this [ __ ] is every day educators met
because no I can't semi-automatic
automatic
well you're saying automatic and and
they're those diapers yeah I have a gun
I don't know what I don't know what it
is yeah and burglar comes in let me
explain what the difference between
semi-auto semi-automatic which you can
purchase in the United States means
every time you pull the trigger one
round comes out of the barrel and the
most layman's terms possible
no no automatic is and so we don't
matter automatic weapons in our yes
there was a weapons know in the 80s
they're illegal so unless they're
predated from that date you you can
purchase them as soon but they're the
quantity there's like they're like a
hundred thousand dollars to buy them so
you really the markets so small you
can't buy them and then you cannot
purchase one as a civilian you'd have to
have a so what's a 47 that is a
semi-automatic rifle today so when
people say well we need a ban
semi-automatics they're not saying that
they're saying we have to ban assault
rifle weapons which we did for a while
in this country of 1994 for a decade and
all the research that back that said it
didn't work at all unfortunately so you
know I'm a constitutionalist first
everybody knows that I'm super pro
Second Amendment so in my opinion all of
this it's like we have to have factual
conversations that are based on fact and
they can be rational right we can't like
I think the problem is it's so
polarizing this debate that the left the
right the middle what do we want in the
United States America preservation of
life and the safety for citizens of
course everybody wants that let's start
there yeah but there's certain ways in
my opinion and I don't want to get into
this too much that we can have more
safety with actually empowering our
citizens to protect themselves because
and let me like this is a question I'd
ask for you guys because from my
viewpoint
we're having lunch together later in
Santa Monica let's say an active shooter
comes out you guys I'm carrying whatever
want to carry isn't that wouldn't you
want to have me as a tool I do and
there's a lot of Americans and well not
only him right but that's where firearm
responsible firearm ownership comes in
straight but you don't say like you have
experience so if there's guys but
there's a lot of guys who aren't
veterans who aren't military or in law
enforcement that are absolutely amazing
shots that know how to carry a firearm
and that's to me why I believe in the
Second Amendment because you guys are
public that can talk about the exception
they might be a little different but
there are a lot of amazing people just
civilians that are shoot better than I
do
less than 1% I Dayton Ohio was taken
down in nine seconds no 37 by a heroic
police officer that saved a lot of lives
a second yeah actually 30 seconds he
killed nine people and wounded 27 hit a
minute right maybe but but I know that
that that here's the way I look at it
for I own guns
um and I agree that that I would rather
have you next to me if a bad guy comes
in or crazy guy comes in I don't want to
be a sitting duck I want a gun to shoot
back at I'd rather I'll take my chances
okay I don't know whether or not if
everybody carries guns of homicides go
up if confrontations go up I don't know
I do I do believe that individuals
should have the right to make their own
choices education a lot of times when
you see people that are gun people
they're very very aware they're very
they're law-abiding first of all they're
they're super safe with guns they know
guns blah blah blah however there is
something to be said about this we live
in a society where we do have actually
very strict measures against the kind of
weaponry civilians can have no one is
basically allowed to have a machine gun
it's really hard to get a machine gun
super expensive you could shave the pin
down you don't you're doing I mean it's
a major problem
so these killings are not done by a guy
opening up with an Uzi clamp removed and
sprang we know they're they're open with
without without with a semi out of it
the other thing that you can't get his
explosives you can't get it's really
hard for anybody who's crazy or anybody
who's even connect or even any videos
money to get grenades though right that
you've got to get grenades to get actual
explosives we really guard against this
which is why you don't have people
detonating themselves I am sure there
are plenty people if they could learn
how to use and you can get
I mean the losses so my eyes and
marathon bombings yeah there's the some
of it but those were those were used
with pressure cookers my point is this
is that it seems to be it seems to me
that legislation is effective and there
has been for ever against certain
weaponry the can't buy a tank can't buy
a missile can't buy a shoulder there we
do have rules we do have sort of
restrictions around Second Amendment
meaning civilians can't have
military-style weapons unless they go to
a shitload of a shitload of loops I mean
like you got to be a prop master in
Hollywood you got there's a thousand but
just to get a gun in general it's easy
it's easy you're running yeah so what
I'm saying is that it is I wonder I
wonder if if we've said it seems to me
that assault white right weapons are
really unforgiving when they hit a human
body conversation here is I and I know I
didn't like read up on anything for I
came in here so I won't speak about talk
about dicks later but you know I think
most say this math you go on weird
obviously shooting it is a problem but
in Neil deGrasse Tyson post of this
terrible timing and he's kind of a
thought but here's the thing about that
is Andrew Schultz and I were talking
about this this morning on text back and
forth he made a great point because he
saw my post he's like I didn't get [ __ ]
for that Bob Bob and I'm like yeah I
know but the thing is is he goes you
know how if you get rid of everyone's
guns or if you wanna make everything
safe if you look at it and he goes you
know there's 250 250 thousand people die
a day by the buy cars so do you want to
make it some some crazy number that's
got to be so that's worldly I think
there's something like that around +30
thousand deaths a year in the United
States from weibull's in that I'll bring
that up chin yeah maybe yeah anything
his point he goes if you wanna make
driving safer to get lower deaths over
this mass shooting us you want everyone
drive 10 miles an hour yeah it was how
safe you want to make it yeah or do you
want people to have the the will the
free will to go 65 70 yeah so yeah was
it 40,000 it says yeah Broadway yes yeah
and if
point five million seriously injured
well that's why you know and it's it's
like you can look point is like if you
make it down to ten miles an hour you no
one's gonna get mad cuz yeah I don't
know if you've been to find the kid we
interrupt non-stop that's okay
no I when your song about assault
weapons I think that's the really hard
part define assault weapon every states
and federally we look at those
completely different and I think
everybody that doesn't know what a
firearm is they're taking a like a two
to three varmint rifle and they're
calling it a salt rifle it's just really
by the appearance it's not really
specified it is some places but I think
that's the problem is like people that
are trying to implement legislation
against the Second Amendment don't
understand firearms and I think that's
where again you need to have like
rational conversations but then again
what when does it kind of end and I
think that's a lot of us on the pro to a
side is if you keep you know infringing
on the Constitution in the Second
Amendment when does that kind of stop
because yeah we're already at a place
but what you don't want got any
automatic weapons well that's all
pistols you know what I'm saying like no
here's a sensible measure what do you do
man there's four hundred million guns
United States I don't have the answer
I'm not smart enough but what I'm saying
is Bernie Sanders
well yeah but like putting in emotional
gun control is what I call it and
knee-jerk reactions to tragedies for
their own political gain is not the
right answer like the right answer is
starts with the why like why are we
doing this why we want to save American
lives and then it goes into how and it
actually has to be tested proven by
facts and data but well how about this
idea
the salt weapons ban didn't prove that
what about sensible like here's an idea
that I think is sensible the fact that
you can go into a gun show in Alabama
Vegas or whatever and buy as many guns
as you want right away and you don't
have any background check to me some
waiting period and well know if it if
you're you have to purchase through an
FFL and you absolutely have to do
paperwork with so you there is
background checks at gun shows I was
told there wasn't the I I've heard that
I don't I'm gonna sound stupid right now
I'm waiting pair two for the license
forgotten forgotten make a transaction
just purchase a firearm you have to go
through an F F
yeah even in a gun show though because I
was told you gotta buy a bunch of guns
and then people says loopholes but
almost every gun show you can't they're
all FFL dealers and they all have to go
through because I thought it started
with this I thought it started with if I
want to sell Brendan a gun it's my
personal possession I can do that way
here goes be most states do not require
a background check for firing purchase
at gun shows from private individuals
private law only requires licensed
dealers can conduct rights so you
private individuals and private
individual usually sells the gun though
and that kid blows everybody right then
that guy's in trouble so to me like it
gets sticky because then you have to say
Brian you have your private property I'm
not allowed to sell a gun to Brennan
without a background check
however I don't think that's a huge
infringement we're talking about a ten
day five day waiting period which I've
already had to do anyway when I bought
my guns I bought it from a licensed well
that exists in a lot of states yes all
right so I wonder though what those
loopholes would it be Tate's it doesn't
seem to be anti Second Amendment to
close those loopholes for people who are
absolutely i all of us agree we don't
want we just don't want to live in a
society where this shit's going on but
the biggest problem Rogan brings this
[ __ ] up all the time sure SSRIs like I
mean those [ __ ] I like about Russians
I'm talking about I'm talking about like
drugs kids that's great well no and I
think an in part I truly believe that
this is like a mental health issues
problem that is kind of being shown as a
gun issue and I know everybody has their
counter points on the left and right and
stuff but like criminal activity is
criminal because you break the law yeah
and we've seen it where vehicles have
slaughtered thirty people driving oh
we've seen it in every format possible
so it's kind of like how do we make
American culture a little more
responsible for their personal safety
and what I mean by that it's not just
necessarily carrying a firearm but hey
at risk people like let's let's activate
law enforcement if some kid has a kill
list and say he's gonna shoot up a
school like let's be proactive like Ohio
it's there's a lot of stuff and we see
similarities across the board all these
people know we do know I don't know the
rules I don't know
Makenna Ohio his mom two weeks prior
called the police because she was
worried he's gonna do something [ __ ] the
police went and there's not much they
can do that I've said conveys a big fat
loser lives in your basement what he
wants to do he makes threats he's on
reddit what he wants to do you can
arrest him for being a loser for
speaking his mind we wanted to arrest
him for having Cheetos all over his
fingers we can't even do that you know
it's like what are we supposed to do
that's what you talk about yes are you a
puffy Cheetos guy or a crunchy Cheetos
guy he dobro but I'm your cheetah I mean
you know 14 days bro you called me thick
you're in shape too though ah dude I got
that book to her bod right now a man is
starting to weigh in going good man yeah
it's kicks off its cause gun control
yeah I know no see at least we had a gun
I don't have a pose I'm trying no reason
why I got what we brought got brought up
right away because you're such like you
know your way around a gun I mean him
are [ __ ] like you compared to you and
the gun so I want your perspective on it
but usually I don't mean like talking
about man like no what are we gonna do
great if you came you drop just this
[ __ ] dime piece of an answer like oh
[ __ ] I think it's gonna be a major
political talking point like you know
talk we're gonna have to talk it's an
agenda for them it's a it sorta seem
point they're not trying to tell me
where the politicians rallied around on
either side around essentially that the
community you know the president flew
out there but like immediately we turn
into something for political gain it's
unfortunate and what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]